you gave the director a hard time and he  was Getti what because he you did an  impression of him directing the movie  while he was directing the movie to his  face constantly  yeah constantly that's very delete all  into a person that's kind of be like  this is how you talk you know  no yeah there is a scene off you guys  remember to begin moving we're all were  drunk and we're having fun and Andy has  this big microphone and he's going like  alright now bill dance dance get up and  dance like Dirty Dancing get up like  Dirty Dancing right now and I'm like  what it's not in the script saw my dirty  dancing it goes yes be like dirty  dancing remember like dirty dancing  Patrick Swayze be like Patrick Swayze  ginnifer dry up in the air and we all  were like we all lost it yes way easy  you idiots that'll show them back you  correct me